okay so today i'm cutting
bangs on my own not a hairstylist here
we go
i'm only doing this because my sister
did it
and it looked really cute except she has
a completely different face shape than
me
and i'm bored all right i don't really
even have the tools
dull scissors and potentially pretty
good scissors
but they haven't been used in forever so
i found a knife sharpener
oh it sounded good no idea what i'm
doing kind of briefly saw people doing
this
really just kind of going for it there
we go
oh i really shouldn't do this okay but
you know screw it
all right i'm gonna do it i don't have a
comb i only have this comb
really not the right comb but it's fine
i'll i'll use the end of this okay
so um i think you do a triangle
from here okay
huh i think that's kind of the vibe
i don't know let's start less and then
we'll go to more
actually let me bring this down here
okay oh my god that's so much hair for
like i have thin hair
but that's a lot of strands i can do
this i can do this
okay i don't even know i'm nervous
you want to make sure that's all even
but it's all baby hairs
on this side i have more baby hairs on
this side than i do on this side the
trick is to keep it
apparently this is terrifying i never
had bangs in my life today's the day
oh i'm so nervous why do nerves kick and
it's so weird it's just bangs like
chill go down and then i turn
and then i take this and i turn again
that doesn't feel right all right let me
do that again
why is this so scary so straight down at
the bridge of the nose
turn and then you grab it and then you
turn
again you know it looks messy i'm going
to do it more
okay why am i shaking oh my god get out
of your comfort zone
not comfortable at all okay
oh it's already been done okay
oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh my god it's okay it's okay
oh [ __ ] i'm not at the bridge of my nose
i did everything wrong
but i can't see if i'm cutting here
[ __ ] all the hairstylists are watching
this being like oh girl
you done [ __ ] up that's uneven holy
okay maybe i'll use my mirror
oh my god
oh no oh no no
oh this is oh this is
oh okay
i mean actually don't i don't hate it a
little uneven
already pretty short thank god i didn't
go shorter definitely a diagonal line
going on on the one side okay
i feel like i can fix this i feel like
i've never had bangs in my
i've never had bangs in my life oh this
is weird
where's all my hair there it is oh
nobody has
what is why is this side so much longer
why something's happening i'm not sure
what so this side is getting longer
maybe if i
reverse the twist boom
boom
okay did that help why why
why are you doing that to me okay [ __ ]
[ __ ] i know falco i didn't tell anybody
i was doing this i didn't even tell
falco i was doing this
oh it's okay okay so let me let me just
let me
start like this it looks like i just
have a little cowlick there i don't even
have a straightener
okay let's see voila there we go
looks great oh [ __ ] that is hot
i think it's too long i think we have to
go shorter i mean it's kind of
cool definitely needs to be actually i
don't know i kind of like it but it's
always going to be in my eyes
it's too long right if anybody can do it
you can do it
you know i also heard about doing this
to make it more like airy and light i
guess you know
i think i fixed it i think i did this i
can do this
if you want bangs you get them bangs
what do you think so far are my babies
huh
do we like it a little
oh now i see the problem
just i don't have enough hair on the
other side
but i'm not hating it harder to see but
i'm not hating it
alright and there's the look
[Music]
do i have a new personality now yes am i
a changed woman
yes am i proud yes do i trust myself
apparently do i recommend this yes
i do i'm very proud johannes you come
here
[Music]
come here
i cut things
come here is that a wig
is it a wig am i a dog mom
do now like it are they too long
i have no idea do you like it or is it
not good
it looks good it's just so different but
it looks good
it looks it looks good is that too long
or no no the sides are supposed to be
longer it's like wispy
do you like it i think i look like a dog
mom now yeah
right like i'm a mother yeah
honey what do you think hello what do
you think
you go to the gym once and this happens
yes i need attention
oh well what do we think do we like
mommy like this
yeah yeah he likes it
it's in my eyeballs yeah is that
annoying or no
no you get used to it i'm just not
seeing i can't see anyway i need like
lasik anyway so it just like compliments
that
right bubba
looks really good i like it thank you
can't wait to see the final result
this is it i thought you're going to do
more did you say you want to cut it
no this is the final result okay no i
like that
i like that i never said it
was good i never said it
you like it that's my baby
i am a legit mom now take that sam my
sister's gonna be like you copied me
hell yeah i did
hell yes i called i copied the hairstyle
i did i did i did oh my god he's so cute
the little booger bear
guys this is falco the flirt and you can
follow him
this is my baby child i just need to
squeeze them
okay sorry you know honestly i don't
know why i didn't do this sooner
in life time for friends reactions i
forgot to
turn on the mic for batch's reaction
so here it is
[Music]
yeah he said bangs
well anyways now that my mic's back on
stupid
i kind of love it i feel like i'm in the
90s or the 80s
the 80s i would like to
just take you out to dinner
why because it'd be beautiful here i'm
sorry
i have to watch my puppy